vous le savez j'ai gardé mon âme
d'enfant ouais merde et aujourd'hui j'ai
découvert le jus du cul
du cul c'est quoi le jus du cul c'est
très simple c'est un peu une petit
carton ça je je cite si ce pour révéler
les pires pensée de tes amis alors je
n'ai pas d'amis ici mais j'ai des jeunes
gens dont vous seriez vous êtes en plus
mes amis mais je vais essayer découvrir
vos pires penser je vous expliquer
comment ça se passe on joue chacun votre
tour je tire une carte au hasard il ya
une question très simple vous avez huit
secondes pour répondre ok sinon vous
buvez un petit jus mais son corps est
très simple on va démarrer pas allez on
va démarrer par non pas guillaume genton
alger ou genton attention c'est parti le
jus du cul 10,3 excuses que tu utilises
quand tu as la bourre le matin mon
réveil n'a pas sonné j'ai dû choisir mes
fringues et je
me suis je me suis lavé les dents
plutôt rouge je roulerai pour lui il
voit petit jus allez c'est parti lequel
cela va se dérouler
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai pas patois
je suis désolé désolé j'en ai pas si on
va jouer maintenant avec berne a manqué
là c'est allé si c'est elle hésite on ne
stoppe le chrono
à la retraite devient confus mais
c'est parti la juge du cul cul citer
trois défauts de ton ex 9h01
salle à
si ça et puis et puis pire à dîner et
moitié du bois ce qu'elle savait que
kouassi dit que ça valait tout bois non
c'est pire que
tout en entier
vous êtes fous moi
c'est partout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est montiel et ces pitres
et rats citoyen de rires
j'adore ce mec s'invite à l'hérault ou
en vendée on enchaîne avec le joker
mois
à deux ans le dock le joker nomme trois
personnes qui pourraient très bien faire
disparaître un cadavre à anne
disparaître un cadavre oui monsieur
benjamin est vraiment
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc à cette question comme sur
vous
passez en fonction de ses fréquentations
bon ça fait mal ça c'est voilà ça peut
arriver sur elle elle va ce que vous
aimeriez a caché un cadavre avec une eva
loubrieu isabelle morini-bosc un jour
voilà vous montre de cacher car vous le
feriez vous raymond que ce rêve où tu as
choisi moi oui mais alors jamais de la
vie il n ya fait
[Rires]
benjamin castaldi mutation il verrait
pas que c'est un canard
mais sa rigueur goût et matthew goode a
choisi également passé à doha mais
jamais par ce n'est pas assez pour je
prenne 20 ans de prison ferme à dire la
vérité c'est une super vie
[Rires]
dure aux jeunes en prison
vous en faire parvenir je vous dis qu au
temps des romains ces défis-là trices
qui a mêlé rural
j'avais pas que ça existait ce mot shit
marib a fait la triste et beau rêve de
tigre
[Rires]
aller souper chaud que la monnaie dans
le système et sérieuse
géraldine maillet tient sa voiture il
faut être prête a dit maja 6-3 raison de
faire payer tout appartenait au resto
mais il a l'argent que moi il veut me
draguer et il vient de me demander en
mariage
à tokyo quelle idée de me dit ah
ouais non merde où la cua sil3 usage
pour tes doigts
[Applaudissements]
on espère tous comme
s'il est plus facile vous plaît saleh
ben ali n'a bien sûr c'est vrai pour
l'instant les cigales merci en tout cas
très bien on pourra jouer avec vous et
vous pourrez
défendre animateur de l'émission je vois
pas d'autres animaux
attention si deux choses à dire à ton
mec et surtout pas ton père what am us
et surtout pas ton père je t'aime je te
prête de l'argent c'est nul bah non pas
celle elle a été enfermée nord at-on
alors tu leur dis tu as une belle ce
n'est que
ces démissions là me donne des droits
mais
ça marche mais c'est passé c'est quoi ta
vie mais la benelli mehdaoui top 6 3
raisons pour ne pas porter de culotte
c'est trop on va faire l'amour est gelée
perdu
dernier c'est bien
remarquez elle peut perdre sa cure
tu perds ses clés salle il a seulement
canon chez omer
où est ce que je l'aimé comme elle a
tenté
de remettre la main dessus c'est pas mal
un fou ça non mes clichés
vous avez perdu votre culotte vabre à
bon port il est des gens très bien c'est
très bien attention
telle fille
si trois raisons de préférer ton voisin
de droite à celui de gauche alors mon
voisin de droite parce qu'elle est
lumineuse parce qu'elle a une belle
veste et pascal un beau sourire bat lui
aussi
[Applaudissements]
r2 s'appelle sont aussi les moins
lumineux il a moins chez les souris papa
noël sont au contraire maintien merci
[Rires]
oui nomme trois personnes que tu
pousserait bien dans l'escalier
bernard montiel benjamin castaldi
benjamin castaldi
[Applaudissements]
mais non
en plus c'est sûr qu'il verra pas de
classe
[Rires]
enfin cela
m'enchante aux 6,3 insulte à dire aux
ligali tunique de
kodwa
mais c'est pas combien je te dois bien
te donne
une montée en puissance s'est pas
[Rires]
abattue
crois que j'étais au restaurant
attention
adieu à ces trois choses plutôt molle
le sexe de pagés maccabi le sexe de base
j'ai vécu avec mes ferrière attendait il
a vécu avec moi parce qu'on sait que ça
va
il n'est jamais très loin de boue
c'est vrai attention mais les
6,3 raison d'aller aux toilettes au
bureau c'est parti j'ai vraiment
vraiment vraiment mourir tellement j'ai
mal il ya quelqu'un de très beaux aux
toilettes je dois aller voir et il faut
y aller me laver les mains et en même
temps donc du coup je fais des deux
je vais
parce que c'est mieux ouais
vous savez quand même des gars t'as pas
fini
la veille à une info sup l'ena 19% des
hommes se masturbe régulièrement aux
toilettes de leur bateau sur leur lieu
de travail je vais faire mais
[Applaudissements]
ça sera réglé ça sera au guidon de sa
machine pas de ça chez nous il y en a
pléthore
ya cinq ans ça veut dire qu'elle n'a
ainsi autour de la table basse et quand
on
sait le seul truc gratuit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le jeune q q vous jouez avec nous
attentions citer trois prénoms de merde
à ne pas donner à ses enfants
baboo castaldi
roméo
juliette
et avec
mes très bons amis les bons on n'a pas
prête c'est le seul animateur quand tu
vas choquante cette folie mettent à
porter
attention
kelly vedova ni citer trois choses que
les hommes font moins bien que les
femmes ont le ménage la cuisine et le
sexe et le quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comment bien longtemps voilà l'aline roc
des faits l'amour bernard franchement il
ya longtemps à lui mais à ton avis j'ai
pas sexe c'est avec clovis
il ya très longtemps c'est vrai il
préfère être là je m'en fous je peux
faire dormir et bouffer
et marché et un pistolet la nuit
dormait chez lui mais il
m'a appelé pour me dire qu'il avait
acheté un pistolet la nuit pour pas voir
se lever c'est vrai
ça pour faire pipi alors je vous
explique ou lave mon dieu je vous
explique du matin [ __ ] celle là
je vous explique c'est vrai c'est vrai
malheureusement c'est vrai je vous
explique pourquoi
j'ai la chance d'avoir une deuxième
chambre demande appartement à paris où
je reçois souvent des amis de bordeaux
ou d'ailleurs donc le problème c'est que
les chiottes ils sont de leur côté et
que donc pour pas les déranger la nuit
d'ouvrir la porte en pleine nuit c'est
vrai je me suis habitué à j'ai acheté un
pistolet parce que j'ai vu ça à
l'hôpital quand je fais là le bétail une
fois et j'ai accepté donc je fais promis
mais c'est un truc vous savez où vous
mettez votre gros sexe dedans
[Rires]
donc vous mettez je recommence votre
gros sexy de danse
et la fête et puis donc vous lever pas
mais ce qui est important si vous saviez
vous
attendez mais n'en attendait ce qui est
important c'est la petite serviette pour
se nettoyer le bout
tu m'étonnes qu'ils baissent pas
[Rires]
et
pire à ces manquements la serna le pire
c'est que c'est vrai mais on sait bien
que vous n'avez pas voter c'est
ma valeur je crois que les chiens
oui sur lui bah ouais non plus avec 400
mg williamson un violeur il lui jette la
pissaladière
ça dans toutes les aires
le gall et
ne reviendra plus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le gars qui sort après tout je
souhaitais j'ai voulu qu'en moyenne
mondiale va pisser dessus
je peux dire c'est pas du bureau et
c'est parti attention
isabelle morini-bosc oui comme tu es
trois choses à ne pas faire lors de sa
première fois la première fois péter
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas compter le globe avec des
lapins bravo le greta
[Rires]
la réponse elle est sortie avec vos mii
tout quoi
attention ménard est
parti non monsieur répartie c'est tout
le monde est opposé à 0 répartie
maintenant que tu prennes
un prompteur
c'était trois avantages d'être un homme
versus une femme le sexe la taille et
l'oseille et le sexe tiger à côté femme
fatale oseille aussi côte entre la
taille buvez buvez
c'était nul vazimba
on ne le fait pas alors si vous êtes un
grand
merci va maintenant à la la la la la
j'ai pas envie qu'il y ait le public
compatibles
[Rires]
on a déjà un mec qui passe partout
s'il vous plaît merci
hormis de ça ici à merci en tout cas pas
leur à castaldi c'est une nouvelle
équipe
répartie mais mister air attention que
de leurs beaux sites et les trois
premières choses que tu ferais su
changer de sexe
ben
je me ferais invité à dîner je me ferai
payer des vacances si je me ferais
pénétrer
mais
dix ans de la femme
c'est très sexiste
décision de la femme et moi avons eu
nous restons libres et qu'ils gagnent
fine kelly vous dirais qu'il ya des
films ont dû inviter au restaurant voilà
et la pénétration c'est déjà le cas non
on ne retrouve
c'est le début d'émission ne peuvent que
jamais
alors à blaye après
certains de vous inquiéter toi et laura
blâme c'est sûr et certain
ça m'a coûté ma existe bien non vraiment
on veut pas on veut pas savoir votre vie
privée
mais je vous dis pas dans quel sens mais
ses pensées ya forcément ça existe bah
oui bien sûr mais bon je ne peux pas
savoir qui fait quoi non là pour ça
aider les gosses et des micros danser
des mégots
mais vous ne serez pas savoir est
diabolique iphone alors ça ça vous
obsède tu te vous obsède
sur la tête de ma mère bon ça fonctionne
tout ça n'a
jamais j'ai demandé sa fin
des personnages ou
menace toute façon hommes femmes il ya
aussi la pénétration anale
[Applaudissements]
la
russie a
toujours fait notre rôle c'est toujours
la vanille côté je vous dire c'est la
carrière de troubles
c'est la ville mais c'est vrai nom est
impossible
ce jeu très prochainement le jus du